A tragic passing, a secret wedding, and
one last heartbreaking phone call — here's
what went down in the final conversation
between Ryan Coogler and Chadwick Boseman.
The release of Black Panther: Wakanda Forever is
sure to be one of the most emotional outings in
the MCU so far. The original film was a massive
success for the franchise, earning over $1.3
billion worldwide, and almost guaranteeing a
sequel in the process. Confirmation of a second
movie came in October 2018, with The Hollywood
Reporter noting that Ryan Coogler had signed a
deal to direct and write the second film. THR also
noted around that time that Chadwick Boseman was
negotiating a deal for $10 million for the sequel
and $20 million for a third Black Panther film.
So much has changed in the years
since the sequel was given the go,
with the MCU fandom still reeling from
the loss of Boseman, who died of colon
cancer in 2020. These emotions are sure
to come flooding back in with the release
of Wakanda Forever, which will deal with
the aftermath of King T'Challa's death.
Ryan Coogler had a lot on his plate with
handling the sequel. The director recently
appeared on an episode of Wakanda Forever: The
Official Black Panther Podcast to discuss the
upcoming film at length. Boseman is at
the heart of the discussion, of course,
and Coogler even recounts their last phone call.
When author and host Ta-Nehisi Coates asks
Coogler when he finished writing the script
for Wakanda Forever, Coogler admits he was
done with it before Chadwick Boseman passed,
which obviously prompted a major rewrite. Coates
subsequently asks what Boseman said when Coogler
called him to see if he wanted to read the
script. After a long silence, Coogler says:
"He was tired, bro. I could tell he was tired."
Coogler says that he had been trying
to get a hold of Boseman for a few days
before they finally connected
for what would be their last
phone call. Referring to Boseman's
wife, Simone Ledward, Coogler said:
"He kicked Simone out cause he told her he didn't
want her to hear nothing that could
get him in trouble with his NDA."
Coogler adds:
"And she didn't wanna leave him.
So I could tell something was up."
Coogler says that Boseman and Ledward
were planning their wedding in South
Carolina — according to Us Weekly, the duo wed
just a few months before Boseman died. Boseman
then asked Coogler about his child, as he had
missed the baby shower that had just been held.
After talking about weddings and children, Ryan
Coogler and Chadwick Boseman's conversation moved
on to the Black Panther sequel. According to
Coogler, Boseman said he didn't want to read the
finished script because he didn't want to get in
the way of any notes the studio might have, so he
said he would read it after they did. The director
later found out that Boseman couldn't read the
script because he was just too tired. Coates then
asked how soon after the phone call Boseman died.
"A couple of weeks. Yeah, man, a couple of weeks."
Coogler's manager and agent called and told him,
but he didn't believe it at first, so he called
Denzel Washington to check if it was true. He
then texted Boseman, hoping it was a rumor;
shortly after, the official press release
went live, and a nightmare became reality.